Thanks again for inviting me for a sleepover tonight, Peter.
I love sleepovers.
Chris, you should always shut off the water when you're not using it.
But how will I brush my teeth without water?
All you need is just enough to get your toothbrush wet like this.
Why do I need to do that?
There's water everywhere.
In oceans, and lakes, and streams, and even when it rains.
Well, you're right but not all that water is safe for us to drink.
Here, imagine this.
If you took all the water in the entire world and put it in one big pool,...
...it will look like this.
See, I told you that's a lot of water.
It might look like a lot, but of all that water,...
...only a tiny bit is safe for us to drink and use every day.
Oh, that's not very much at all.
No, it's not.
That's why we have to be smart about how we use it.
Wow, you're right, Peter.
I didn't think of that.
It's always smart to save water.